[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le journal
de tv 78 ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité locale et régionale voici
les titres de ce jeudi 28 novembre
dépenses de fonctionnement en baisse
investissements en hausse à destination
des transports des lycées de la sécurité
la présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse a présenté les
principaux objectifs du prochain budget
de la collectivité le détail dans cette
édition
jusqu'à samedi plaisir organise sa
quatrième semaine du handicap des
sensibilisations notamment auprès des
jeunes avec des animations sur le
handisport collégiens et élèves de
primaire ont pu s'initier au basket et
au tennis de table en fauteuil roulant
enfin cette maison d'édition est
installé à voisins le bretonneux rue du
monde participent jusqu'a lundi au salon
du livre et de la presse jeunesse à
montreuil un stand et des ateliers
proposés en cette année spéciale des 30
ans de la convention internationale des
droits de l'enfant et à suivre pour ce
week-end des idées de sorties à plaisir
et à maurepas
cette information pour commencer à
villepreux le complexe sportif alain
mimoun va être réquisitionnée par la
préfecture des yvelines à partir du 3
décembre
le site devrait accueillir une centaine
de réfugiés tibétains installé à ce jour
sous des tentes sur un terrain vague à
achères le campement doit être démantelé
cet hiver est la prise en charge serait
assurée par les services de l'état
également par une association locale un
accueil en attente de trouver des
solutions de relogement cette
réquisition nécessitera le transfert de
certaines activités sportives à l'espace
saint michel petrucciani est la mairie
de villepreux assure dans un communiqué
une permanence de ses activités à 100%
[Musique]
c'est la tradition enfin et en début
d'année les collectivités discute et
discutent et votent leur budget la
région ile de france a prévu de
l'adopter en séance plénière du 16 au 18
décembre sa présidente valérie pécresse
a présenté les grandes lignes de ce
budget cette semaine les précisions de
nos confrères de via grand paris l'us
métro rer ou tramway l'amélioration des
transports reste l'enjeu majeur pour la
région ile de france elle prévoit une
enveloppe de 834 millions en 2020 l'état
n'est pas au rendez vous de ses
engagements et que quand la région
investit 800 millions l'état lui a
promis de mettre 400 millions et
qu'aujourd'hui il me dit qu'il va mettre
que 190 millions et 6 ne met que 190
millions ça veut dire que il ya des
projets qui vont devoir être arrêté en
ile-de-france tout la transformation des
rer
les tn les tramways et peut-être même
des projets de prolongation de métro ou
la prolongation du rer e à la défense
avec un budget de 4,2 milliards d'euros
la région accélère ses investissements
il grimpe à 2,2 milliards d'euros +41 %
par rapport à 2015 le budget de
fonctionnement continue de baisser 1,9
milliard soit 20% de moins par rapport à
autre engagement faire de la région un
territoire de propriétaire elle annonce
la suppression de surprime d'assurance
imposé aux personnes malades
nous avons provisionné le montant qui
permettra à tous les emprunteurs qui se
présenteront devant un certain nombre de
réseaux bancaires de pouvoir demander la
garantie la région et d'avoir zéro
surprime d'assurance du fait de leur
maladie pour tous ceux qui ont été
malades ou qui sont porteurs d'une
pathologie chronique séropositifs
malades atteints de mucoviscidose ou
d'hépatite la région ile de france
prévoit aussi de former trois mille cinq
cents policiers au recueil de plaintes
des femmes victimes de violences et on
ile de france justement ces deux
départements ont entamé un rapprochement
depuis 2016 yvelines et hauts-de-seine
ont lancé hier un portail commun
1 78 92 rassemble en une seule
plateforme 250 dispositifs informant les
habitants des avancées sur le projet de
fusion est mais aussi des services et
aides proposées par les deux
collectivités
mélanie poker quatre chiffres pour mieux
partager les informations les yvelines
et les hauts-de-seine ont dorénavant
leur si commun un travail porté pendant
dix mois par les équipes des deux
départements
on est plus fort à deux que tout seul et
chacun profite aussi de l'expérience de
l'autre et finalement c'est toujours un
ajustement vers le haut et jamais vers
le bas ce que nous voulons mettre en
oeuvre aussi bien à travers la fusion
qu'à travers les progrès que nous
faisons
administrativement techniquement dans
cette fusion celle inverse
c'est donc que c'est l'administration se
met au service de l'usager au service du
citoyen neuf thématiques 250 dispositif
accessible des parcours type prédéfini
ou des profils
le site s'adresse aux particuliers comme
aux professionnels c'est l'ensemble des
aides et des dispositifs qui sont
présentés sur ce site qui sont regroupés
donc en un seul site c'est l'avantagé
effectivement de ces projets là c'est
qu'ils ont toute la formation dont ils
souhaitent bénéficier pour constituer
leur dossier dead hand celle du site sur
la partie route on à la voirie les
routes départementales et donc nos
usagers vont pouvoir se dire tiens
est ce qu'il y ait prévu des travaux sur
les routes départementales
donc c'est pas un dispositif en tant que
tel mais c'est une manière de ceux
d'avoir de l'information les démarches
peuvent se faire à tout moment de la
journée le site est accessible 24 heures
sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7
direction plaisir toute la semaine la
ville organise sa quatrième semaine du
handicap avec notamment le sport qui est
à l'honneur pour sensibiliser les jeunes
des activités pour les collégiens et les
élèves de primaire au programme basket
fauteuil tennis de table ou encore
gymnastique handisport le reportage de
michael et demi d'euros des ateliers
pour se glisser dans la peau d'un
sportif en situation de handicap pour la
quatrième année consécutive la ville de
plaisir organise au palais des sports
ces journées destinées aux enfants de la
commune scolarisés en primaire et au
collège
objectif sensibiliser la nouvelle
génération sur la situation de handicap
qu'ils puissent se projeter un petit peu
sûres
sur les différents types de handicaps
physiques pour le coup qu'on a et qu'on
va représenter sur cette semaine et que
les enfants puissent en parler autour
d'eux par la suite et se rendre compte
de l'importance des difficultés les
personnes handicapées
on se mouvoir de faire des activités
mais aussi des possibilités c'est pas
parce que on se retrouve en situation de
handicap qu'on ne peut plus rien faire
au programme notamment de cette journée
du tennis de table handisport les jeunes
ont pu tester la discipline avec un
bandeau sur les yeux ou sur des chaises
votre activité farid et le basket
fauteuil est assez compliqué déjà de se
diriger de faire des dribbles et de
marquer surtout faucon-lambert réussir
parce qu'on est barque on est dans un
fauteuil donc pour tirer faut
s'entraîner on voit que c'est difficile
et qu'ils veulent quand même quand même
le faire au total près de 600 jeunes de
la ville participent à ces journées de
sensibilisation dans le cadre de la
semaine du handicap
une cinquième édition sera programmée
l'année prochaine et on retournera tout
à l'heure à plaisir pour parler de la
fête du jeu qui est organisée ce samedi
une société yvelinoise distingué lors du
dernier mondial du bâtiment en début
novembre choco installé opérait en
yvelines s'est vu décerner un award de
l'innovation découverte de ce
spécialiste de la menuiserie en
aluminium et pvc avec mélanie poker une
reconnaissance de 35 mm d'épaisseur
c'est avec cette création que choko
vient d'obtenir un de ward la façade fws
ce 35 panoramique design représente deux
ans de travail en allemagne maison mère
de l'entreprise et un nom peu
d'adaptation par les équipes françaises
c'est une demande récurrente aujourd'hui
du marché un besoin un accès à la
transparence à l'extérieur une
perception une visibilité et justement
les solutions les produits aluminium
sont en temps normal un frein donc plus
on minimise l'impact de la masure nuance
portes et murs on profite justement de
nos murs extérieurs la finesse a
toujours été une recherche notamment de
la part des architectes et on le voit
aussi un bien-être un confort pour
l'utilisateur final
installé depuis 1965 en france choco
travail l'aluminium et le pvc et conçoit
façades fenêtres et portes
le site emploie près de 300 personnes de
la création au test vous avez en fait en
fonction des typologies de produits soit
on va partir d'un travail mené en prêt
au préalable en allemagne et sinon il ya
des produits qui sont franco français
que nous développons totalité ici au
père en yvelines donc on part d'une
étude de marché d'une définition de
produits d'un besoin
et puis après on va tout simplement
travailler le développement ou
l'amélioration d'une gamme existante la
façade primé est commercialisé depuis
l'entreprise distribue en métropole dans
les dom-tom l'afrique francophone et
l'afrique du nord
au chapitre culturel le 35 le 35e salon
du livre et de la presse jeunesse se
déroule à montreuil dans le 93 jusqu'à
lundi comme chaque année à la maison
d'édition vie sinoise rue du monde à son
stand et ses auteurs présents pour des
dédicaces et des ateliers année
particulière ans et 30 ans de la
convention internationale des droits de
l'enfant marylène iapichino étaient sur
place ce matin
450 exposants présents au salon du livre
et de la presse jeunesse le plus grand
d'europe consacré à cette littérature et
parmi eux rue du monde
la maison d'édition évinoise vient tous
les ans mettre en avant ses nouveautés
cette année sont particulièrement
centrée sur les droits des enfants et
l'environnement qu'elle aura conservé ma
planète
parce qu'aussi maintenant hors du monde
publie beaucoup de livres sur l'écologie
face à devenir de plus en plus urgent
est
c'est aussi important de sensibiliser
les enfants à la beauté de la planète et
à leur droit d'avoir une planète je
reste un peu un impact si c'est possible
ou sous sol du salon en fait l'éloge de
la lenteur la thématique de cette 35e
édition ici maya saft rome une autre
issue et d'oise édité par maison du
monde apprend à cette classe d'une école
de bobigny à dessiner des motifs dans
les illustrations que je fais en tout
cas ses albums là qui sont proposés je
n'utilise pas de couleur donc ce qui est
assez peu courant quand on parle de
l'album jeunesse mais par contre je
représente la couleur à travers des
motifs et donc j'ai essayé de leur
expliquer comment moi je travaillais et
là je leur propose des motifs et comment
on peut représenter les couleurs donc à
les reproduire les femmes qu'on faisait
j'ai choisi des vagues du triangle
les enfants se laissent aller leur
imagination au du monde de son côté
présente au stand f12 jusqu'à la fin du
salon
temps forts le lundi 2 décembre à 13h30
avec une rencontre débat sur
l'environnement
[Musique]
allez c'est l'heure dans ce journal de
vous donner quelques idées de sorties
pour le week-end dans les yvelines deux
invités pour parler de ses idées magali
pas un bon soir on parle avec vous dans
un instant du salon de noël que vous
organisez avec votre association à mort
parce ce dimanche on va commencer avec
vous et ginette faro bonsoir on cela
vous êtes adjointe à la famille aux
solidarités pour la ville de plaisir la
municipalité organise ce samedi elle a
fait du juste un véritable marathon du
jeu qui va durer de 14h jusqu'à une
heure du matin à la maison des familles
flora tristan ce fait plusieurs années
que la ville organise cet événement
pourquoi le proposait et bien déjà pour
vous dire en préambule nous faisons
cette fête du jeu depuis 2012 et
pourquoi proposer cette fête c'est parce
que on se rend compte que autour du jeu
il se passe plein de choses
alors on peut voir qu'il y a de
l'intergénérationnel les parents les
enfants les plus petits puisque nous
avons nous aurons quinze professionnels
de la famille de la direction des
familles et des solidarités qui seront
là et notamment pour les crèches pour
les tout petits services de la ville à
contribution aussi les associations de
dieu les associations également et bien
sûr c'est un partenariat étroit que nous
entretenons avec tous les acteurs qui
sont sur la ville qu'ils soient
associatifs ou bien évidemment qu'ils
soient des services de la ville donc les
objectifs c'est vraiment de faciliter
les rencontres favoriser les rencontres
entre générations puisque ça s'adresse à
vraiment à tout le monde cette fête du
jeu oui cette fête s'adresse des tout
petits du bébé on peut dire jusqu'à la
personne retraitée joueurs voire
davantage et c'est pour cette raison
également que nous faisons une soirée de
20h jusqu'à 2 heures du matin pour les
personnes qui l auront un petit peu plus
de technicité dans certains jeux puisque
ce ne seront pas les mêmes jeux qui
seront proposés à cet horaire là que les
jeux qui seront proposés dans l'après
midi
mais justement à quel type de jeu on va
jouer sur cette fête à plaisir alors sur
la fête on va jouer à des caps là
puisque les jeux de construction c'est
quelque chose qui peut effectivement des
papas des mamans avec leurs enfants et
moi ce que j'ai souhaité c'est que les
agents de la ville et d une formation
justement pour pouvoir encadrer les
personnes qui veulent faire ces
constructions puisque je pense que vous
savez ce que c'est dès les quarts place
ce sont des petites des petites planches
à ses anciens comme jeu et on
encore aujourd'hui complète face
intéresse les petits oui oui ça
m'intéresse
non seulement les pays le plus grand
mais les plus grands également et puis
il y aura aussi des jeux de quilles qui
s'appelle d'ailleurs vasile ans et donc
voilà des jeux qui il ya le chantier
donc scellé avec des lego également donc
ça c'est pareil ils sont des choses je
te plais générations ont connu et
continue continue à jouer
il y aura aussi l'association du
quartier du conseil de quartier du val
hibou qui va présenter des jeux
stratégiques avec de la houle est là où
aller est un jeu qui a été créée en
afrique et qui se joue avec des trous ou
avec des creux et avec des cailloux des
voilà des choses comme ça donc la part
belle au jeu de toute la planète et de
toutes générations
on s'inscrit à l'événement pour pour y
venir il faut s'inscrire au préalable
alors pour dans la journée c'est pas
forcément souhaitable
enfin c'est pas c'est pas indiquée mais
puisque c'est ouvert à tout le monde
c'est cette une fête qui est ouvert à
tout le monde mais par contre pour le
soir oui et le soir il faudra que les
jeunes qui participent et plus de 12 ans
d'accord de 12 à 99 ans je crois on peut
avoir fait pour venir dans la tête
davantage puisque nous avons des
centenaires sur plaisir à cette zone du
jeu du morcellement vraiment ouverte à
toutes les générations blasien événement
s'est scindée en deux de 14 heures à 19
heures c'est ouvert à tous et à partir
de 20h jusqu'à une heure du matin on va
jouer jusqu'à retrait jusqu'à tard dans
la nuit on va se coucher tard pour les
12 ans et plus
à plaisir merci ginette farrow et d'être
revenu en parlant plateau je rappelle
que vous êtes adjointe au maire de
plaisir à la famille aux solidarités 1
et pour cette fête du jeu vous avez bien
sûr toutes les informations sur le site
internet de la ville de plaisir
autre événement dont nous parlons dans
ce journal le salon de noël c'est ce
dimanche au bar au bar le social à
maurepas
première édition de cet événement
organisé par votre association magali
pain je rappelle que vous êtes la
présidente de l'association léo déjà
juste pour présenter les eaux les
objectifs de léo c'est d'organiser des
événements au profit de oeuvres
caritatives
c'est tout à fait ça donc des événements
divers donc ça peut être culturel ça
peut être des salons bien-être ça peut
être des salles noël ça peut être
vraiment divers événements et toujours
en fait au profit d'une association
caritative
donc pour l'instant c'est des
associations qu'on connaît enfin que je
connais personnellement et qui sont pour
la défense des animaux d'accord donc on
va en parler je pense un peu bon voilà
c'est cesser le principe est pourquoi
cet engagement justement en faveur
d'autres associations
pourquoi au départ moi j'avais le
souhait de créer moi-même un refuge et
je me suis aperçu qu'ils avaient déjà
tellement d'associations qui existent
que j'ai préféré me dire je vais créer
des événements et les aider plus tôt ces
associations qui existent déjà qui ont
besoin de fonds pour fonctionner pour
développer des actions tout à fait
exactement
et du coup le type de d'événements vous
en avez parlé que vous avez déjà
organisé là il y aura ce salon de noël
ce week-end à maurepas mais quels sont
les autres types d'événements alors en
fait c'est une association qui est tout
jeune ça elle date de l'année dernière
donc le premier événement qu'on a pu
faire l'année dernière c'est un salon du
bien-être
donc on a rassemblé des praticiens
bien-être en réflexologie kiné
kinésiologie vraiment différentes choses
aussi des cosmétiques de la lingerie fin
ça passe pas vraiment beaucoup de choses
le bien-être finalement et on a pu du
coup donné 250 euros à l'ask donc et une
association de plaisir du coup et qui en
fait récupère les chats abandonnés et
les fait stériliser parce que en fait ça
prolifère beaucoup les chats dans la
nature donc ils défoncent stériliser
leur trouver des familles d'accueil
il est soigné au besoin et il est rond
et leur trouve des familles définitive
c'est au profit d'une association qui on
va dire ben de même type ces familles
les wanted qui a basé à elancourt
oui exactement et là c'est un peu le
même principe d'ailleurs j'ai connu
famille mounted par le biais de la sq a
cédé associations qui se connaissent
très bien
voilà j'ai voulu faire pour l'asca au
départ parce que je les connaissais et
puis famille lointaine ensuite et c'est
un peu le même principe il ya beaucoup
plus de bénévoles
auprès de family wanted mais voilà c'est
un peu le même principe sauf que c'est
dans une ville différente si on résume
les objectifs d'un tel salon l'a compris
aider d'autres associations caritatives
là en l'occurrence ce sera pour family
wanted c'est aussi là on a la proche de
noël c'est trouver quelques idées
cadeaux
c'est ça aussi paul a fait alors il se
sera que ça il y en a plein d'idées
cadeaux que ce soit y aura des
confitures maison moi j'aime bien voilà
prévaloir le local où les petits
entrepreneurs en fait moi je suis
entrepreneur aussi à la base donc ce que
j'aime c'est regrouper tout le monde
dans un événement et que tout le monde
puisse voilà avoir la chance de partager
ses produits ou ses services
donc là il y aura un peu de tout il y
aura des cosmétiques des confitures
maison il y aura des boîtes en plastique
des bougies enfin il y aura un peu de
tout effectivement on pourra trouver
plein d'idées cadeaux et en plus au
profit d'une association enquête
et pourquoi elle à choisir de koufa
billund site parce que c'est voilà deux
du même ordre que les autres
associations qui aident les animaux
justement ces signes ces thématiques qui
vous tient à coeur
oui tout à fait pas déjà moi j'ai adopté
méchas par le biais de ses associations
là parce que voilà je trouve ça
important et moi les animaux c'est vrai
que c'est une cause qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur
je suis végétarienne tout ça je fais
voilà je suis très très à fond là-dedans
donc je vais privilégier un peu ces
associations là mais après je suis pas
contre d'autres associations qui sont
pour les enfants pour enfin voilà peu
importe la cause
voilà parce que voilà c'est la cause que
vous avez choisi on l'a dit idéal pour
trouver des idées de cadeaux plusieurs
idées à trouver sur place
l'entrée sera gratuite du coup comment
comment vous allez récolter ces dons
comment par quel biais ils seront
récoltés ces dons alors du coup on
organise une tombola
donc là les tombolas cela marche bien en
général donc chaque chaque exposant en
fait va faire don d'un lot et
ras du cou pas mal de l'eau pour cette
tombola et les gens achètent des tickets
c'est ça qui va faire qu'on va pouvoir
avoir aussi des bénéfices
et puis les exposants alors en fonction
de ce qu'ils y gagnent aussi ça peuvent
nous aussi nous reverser une part de
leurs bénéfices
ils peuvent également vous aider une
dernière question pour un événement
réussi quels sont les ingrédients
bah écoute et de la convivialité déjà de
la bienveillance entre les exposants les
gens qui viennent et c'est après je
pense qu'effectivement il ya des petites
choses qui attire les gens et qui font
que ça marche
là pour le coup on va on fait venir un
père noël donc pour les enfants c'est
top
on va faire des chants de noël aussi
c'est une troupe de chant des
clayes-sous-bois justement de laquelle
je fais partie donc ils vont chanter
comme ça
gracieusement pour nous enfin voilà
plein de petites choses c'est un bar en
plus qui se trouve juste à côté d'auchan
et c'est donc très bien placé je pense
qu'il peut y avoir du monde et rendez
vous de 10h à 18h au par le social c'est
au rond-point laurent schwarz à maurepas
toutes les informations sur la page
facebook de l'association léo merci
magali pain d'être venu en plateau
présidente de cette association et merci
encore à ginette faro pour être venu
parler de la fête du jeu à plaisir ce
week-end les premiers marchés de noël se
tiennent à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le cas dans trois communes à
coignières le rendez vous est fixé
samedi de 10 heures à 18 heures sur la
place de l'église saint germain
d'auxerre stand mini ferme pédagogique
balades en poney est venue du père noël
à 15 heures le père noël qui sera de
passage aussi à magny les hameaux où le
marché se tient samedi et dimanche c'est
organisé par l'association des acteurs
économiques de la commune à la salle des
fêtes
le trait d'union enfin ce sont trois
jours de festivités qui vous attendent à
la ferme du manet à montigny le
bretonneux
à partir de demain 130 stands pour la
28e édition avec un chalet aussi un
dédié pour le père noël le programme
complet sur les sites internet des
communes à elancourt une mise à jour
poétique ludique non conformiste de
marilyn monroe c'est ce qui vous attend
jusqu'à la fin du mois de novembre donc
jusqu'à ce week-end au prisme à
elancourt updates marilyn vous plonge
dans la vie de l'icône avec notamment et
des photos inédites
au rayon ce
[Musique]
à la fois drôle sensuel fragile
ce sont toutes les facettes de l'actrice
et chanteuse glamour qui sont exposés
aux prises mahé long cours
update marilyn a été imaginé par la
compagnie principe actif
objectif faire revenir marilyn monroe à
notre époque et des clichés pris par
l'un de ses photographes officiels
milton greene ont été réintégrés dans
des photos d'aujourd'hui c'est son fils
joshua green qui a resterait tous les
négatifs de son père avec sa société
archives images et nous a confié ses
photos et ses photos nous les avons
réintégré dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
elles viennent se mêler alors ça c'est
en exclusivité c'est vraiment pour pour
le pour le prisme des photographies de
la collection personnelle de jeu
chagrine piétons qui ont été restaurées
qu'il nous a fait tirer sur papier
japonais et qui sont imprimés à les
tâches du théâtre at on jamais exposé
ses pots dont tous les recoins du lieu
culturel ont été investis par ces
composites au cours du parcours le
public peut également découvrir le
témoignage de l'épousé de milton greene
l'idée de cette exposition est de
balayer les idées préconçues sur l'icône
des années 50 et de lui rendre hommage
elle était représentée par le hollywood
comme étant extrêmement sexué avec une
image très très glamour et puis c'était
quelqu'un qui avait une vie intérieure
extrêmement riche qui est extrêmement
fine cultiver féministe mais quand même
une installation qui se veut ludique et
interactive avec notamment un jeu sur
smartphone
le public est également mis à
contribution ses pages et minutes juste
une expo où les gens viennent et puis
regardons ils peuvent s'impliquer
donc s'il voit marilyn cela si vous
entendez vous voyez marelli mme dans
votre cuisine dans votre librairie
n'hésitez pas la photographier de et à
nous envoyer la photo parce que marilyn
viendra rejoindre l'exposition
cette exposition fait partie d'un
dispositif transmédia le 30 novembre le
public pourra découvrir sur la scène du
prisme sa confession une achevé seul
texte autobiographique de l'icône
glamour et puis j'accueille mélanie
poquet bonsoir de la rédaction tv 78
vous serez aux commandes dans quelques
minutes et du 7-8 loisirs vous ne
parlerez pas encore de noël ça c'est
pour plus tard mais du téléthon émission
spéciale pour faire le tour des
rendez-vous dans les environs parce que
la solidarité sera partout sur saint
quentin en yvelines et au delà le
téléthon c'est le week-end prochain
c'est les vendredis 6 et les samedis 7
décembre
ceux de nombreuses animations vous
attendent sur de nombreuses communes
alors ce soir on fera un focus sur le
club de plongée de saint quentin en
yvelines qui propose des baptêmes de
découvrir la nage avec des pales et se
lance aussi un challenge
il faudra faire un rôle et on l'appelait
je reçois aussi les organisateurs du
téléthon sur la ville de coignières
allant dans leur programme il ya des
découvertes sportives des
sensibilisation au handicap des jeux des
concerts et tous les autres rendez vous
seront aussi à découvrir tout à l'heure
le 7-8 loisirs c'est dans un instant sur
tv 60,18 merci mélanie voilà c'est la
fin de ce journal merci de l'avoir suivi
demain vendredi vous avez rendez vous
avec le 7-8 l'hebdo qui reviendra sur
l'essentiel de l'actualité de la semaine
avec une invitée demain la députée des
yvelines marie le bec belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]